We know this value inside needs to be greater than 7 or this value inside can be
less than negative 7. Remember to catch that inequality sign, we have to reverse
it for the negative answer. We can subtract 1 from both sides and then divide by
2. So x is greater than 3. That's one part of our solution. For the other
inequality, I subtract 1 from both sides, then divide by 2, so x is less than
negative 4. On a number line, we have x greater than 3, and x less than negative
4. Remember, any number in either region, this region or this region, will work
for my inequality. If x is any value in here or any value in here the condition
is satisfied. In the interval notation we'd have negative infinity comma
negative 4. We use parenthesis because we can include these values. Then the
union because you want this or this region other than 3 to positive infinity
again with parenthesis. If you got that one right, excellent work.